what are your thoughts about lifelong
monogamy and what's your thoughts
about polyamory given that we've been
talking about ideas of mate switching
and poaching and all that kind of stuff
yeah i think that we evolved to be i
prefer the term
uh pair bonded
um
species so pair bonding is one of the
strategies purebond long-term mating is
one of the strategies but that doesn't
necessarily mean for decades and decades
or life long because we often pierbond
serially so we'll get into a
relationship
that might last a year or five years and
then break up and then form another
relationship so we engage in cereal
mating
we engage in
infidelity we engaged and we engaged in
some short-term
uh mating um and uh so we have a what i
described as a menu of mating strategies
and which particular
mating strategy an individual adopts
depends on a wide variety of factors it
i think some are just kind of personal
proclivities some depend on your mate
value so if you are
an eight to nine or a ten you have more
options for what mating strategy you
want to pursue um if you're a one or a
two you're not going to be able to
be polyamorous
in all likelihood
um there's a lot of attention to
polyamory now
and
it's unclear whether this whether
there's an increase in it or whether
people are just talking about it more
it is the case and i know
i know several people who are in
polyamorous relationships and i've
talked
with them in detail about them and
jealousy is often a factor in that and
they describe it as kind of like um
uh an emotion that has to be somehow
tamed or dealt with in in some way
and so and so in polyamory there are
many different types of polyamory so in
like one type for example is you have a
primary
love partner and then
some others on the side that are
permitted
usually within in consensual terms
within
a an explicit contract the the cup that
the primary partners work out so it's
okay if you
you know i know as one couple that's
okay if you do it outside the city
limits
of los angeles but not within
some say it's okay for thursday but i
want the weekend friday and saturday
nights to me
it's okay if there's
sexual involvement but no emotional
involvement so there are different type
different strategies that people work
out and some of them are designed to try
to keep jealousy at bay so i think it's
an evolved emotion there's a natural
emotion that that people experience
um now interestingly there's there's a
while we're on this topic there's a sex
difference therein um
namely if you contrast sexual
jealousy with emotional jealousy or
sexual infidelity with emotional
infidelity and so we we
in one set of studies i put my
participants or we used to call them
subjects
into this what i call the sophie's
choice of the jealousy dilemmas i said
imagine your partner became interested
in someone else and you discover that
they have had uh
passionate sexual intercourse with this
person
and they've gotten emotionally involved
with them they've fallen in love with
them
which aspect of the infidelity upsets
you more
and when you
and that's why it's called the sofia
shirts both terrible choices
yeah uh but men much more likely to say
the sexual
infidelity is what upsets me more women
it's like why even ask me it's a
no-brainer 85 percent of women say the
emotional infidelity is what bothers me
more
a former student of mine uh barry cooley
did a really interesting study of uh
analysis of this
reality show called cheaters i've
actually never seen it but
where where if you
suspect your partner of cheating then
the detective from the tv team will
follow the person
uh and then they'll call up and say
we've just seen you found your husband
here in the no-tell motel do you want to
come down and talk to him and so the and
so what he analyzed though was the
verbal interrogations that people had
when they confronted their partner and
women wanted to know
are you in love with her
men wanted to know
did you [ __ ] him
or did you have sex with them and so is
it's this sex difference in sensitivity
to these
different cues of infidelity and and of
course there's there's an evolutionary
logic to this to this sex difference and
it's been replicated not not the cheater
study but um
the uh hypothetical
sophie's choice studies been replicated
now in sweden and china and you know
it's a universal sex difference
so given that sex difference and you
mentioned another one that just returned
to which is uh
in the engineering disciplines yeah
person thing or presentation so until i
started to see
writing about it in the sort of
psychology
literature i observed this anecdotally a
lot and the reason i observed it is i
was confused so i care a lot about
robots i'm a robotics person and so a
lot of
males in the robotics community really
didn't care about the what's called the
human robot interaction problem which is
like robots when they interact with
humans
and then a lot of females all brilliant
in in the robotics community cared about
the human robot interaction they cared
about the human the what the robot
colleague communicates with him the
human in the picture human in the loop
and i was really confused like because
the difference to me in my anecdotal
interactions
but the the n is quite large there like
i you know i'm in the robotics community
i know a lot of people yeah and i was
confused because for me
i really care about human robot
interaction i i see i care about both a
lot and
and
in the same thing here in terms of
emotional cheating versus physical
cheating
i care a lot about both and i have like
this oscillating brain so i wonder what
that says about
my brain so often wonder this because
there's specific sex differences that
are represented in the data in the
literature and i seem to oscillate
depending on mood
yeah and i wonder what that says about
me
why do i care so much about that robot
on the floor
i care not
uh half i care about how it works
and the other half
how makes other people feel yeah what is
that yeah so so i guess what i would say
this gets back to our earlier discussion
of agency and communion where
i actually think that
it's a sign of being
well balanced to have both capacities
uh within use and so
you get um people who are um
unimodal or they just have one mode of
operating let's say it's the thing mode
which which engineers tend to be good at
you you have to be good at it to be a
good engineer because things have to
actually work yes you know it's not in
some you know dream or hypothetical
state things have to have to actually
work
but with the agency and community i
think it's good to have a balance and
that's why i think some of the best
romantic relationships are those where
people are
they're high on what they used to call
androgyny where they have both the
positive
features of agency and communion the
positive features of masculinity and
femininity
uh within the same mix but also with the
footnote of not the unmitigated agency
or unmitigated communion both of which
can be
negative and so i view these as um
capacities and some people are out of
balance some people have a good balance
between the two it sounds like you have
a good balance between the two well but
also the allocation i feel like it's a
very dynamic thing
it's like uh
um
um at least that where
for me personally
of the beauty between humans
of the dance of the push and pull
of the different moods
it's like a dynamical system it's not
two static entities fully represented
and consistent through every interaction
sometimes you know um
people might confuse the fact that i
often talk about love and i
i love humans that i don't have a temper
that i don't have like
i lose my [ __ ] all the time
especially like on things i really am
passionate about like people i work with
and so on yeah i'm all over the place
and there's but underneath it there's a
deep love and respect for humans but
like i lose my [ __ ] all the time um
and
that that chaos that roller coaster
i think that's what makes human
relations awesome i mean that the the
push and pull of it of course it can
oscillate too far which is when it
becomes amber her type of situation when
it turns to emotional or physical
violence when it turns to jealousy
crosses a a line where it's hurtful and
there's
like
that it crosses that
vast grey landscape of what is abuse
uh versus what is
just a
beautiful turmoil of human nature right
yes
yeah and it's it's complicated it's uh
yeah yeah it's complicated and it's it's
dynamic and
i would just add i thought you phrased
that brilliantly
but i would just add to that it also
depends on sort of what you're trying to
do and so i think some of the
oscillation
can be what
task what problem you're trying to solve
and so if you're i don't know trying to
you know build a bridge or something you
need to be very thin oriented and
you know make sure the damn thing
actually
works and doesn't collapse when a car
goes over it
if you're trying to
form a
relationship um
you know and you're entirely
thing-oriented it's not gonna work you
know uh
and that's that's one of the people
one of the things with uh and males tend
to be more um on this on the so-called
spectrum
uh side of things where
one of the hallmarks is a deficit in
social
mind reading
just to add to your point about i guess
i've already made it that of the dynamic
properties of the roller coaster is
depending on what problem you're trying
to solve you might want to toggle back
and forth to one pole or the other